sultan david is a former world champion
spring kayaker and he has brought in a
few other fellow champions in an attempt
to beat a current world record right
here in las vegas sultan david's joining
us to talk about the preparation and
what it takes to beat a record how's it
going how are you thank you for
having us of course so we were just
talking about this this is a big deal
this is happening tomorrow let's talk
about the current world record and what
you guys are trying to do yes so we're
definitely trying to beat the record the
current world record which is our 2447
from hoover dam from the famous hoover
dam down south on the colorado river
roughly 12 miles kayaking that's gonna
be a full force out it's not a float on
the river and the finish line is right
by the ramp of the willow beach marina
wow i'm tired just thinking about that
tell us who you brought along and how
this is
a current olympic champion with me
chandra todka and an olympic fort benson
adage they both by the way world
champions and they also hold the world
record in a double kayak wow so you guys
have quite the team going on here are
you guys ready for it are you feeling
confident
actually i want my olympic gold medal in
200 meters it's about uh 35 seconds so
35 seconds then one and a half hour it's
a big step for me but yeah definitely
going to be a challenge for us so how
have you guys prepared where do you even
begin to make sure you can beat this
world record yeah we started
many many years ago for this obviously
so but right now they came to lake las
vegas for a training camp with me and
about three weeks now we've been
training together every day three times
so i think they are ready and i can be
honest i'm the weak link in the chain
here so
i'm sure you guys are going to come
together and you're going to do it this
is happening tomorrow you said around 9
a.m 9 00 am getting on the water warming
up the start is going to be right at 9
15 a.m and we hopefully we're going to
pass the finish line around 10 35 las
vegas local time all right you can do it
and this is really important it's really
fun to break a world record but let's
just talk about the importance of
raising awareness i mean i don't even
know what goes into all this so this is
really important to talk about it
exactly so many people don't even know
las vegas has these beautiful places to
kayak to start with right lake las vegas
or the colorado river they are perfect
for our sport so we're trying to raise
awareness and attention for this port
the spring kayaking and the kayaking
itself it's a beautiful outdoor sport
and i i know you now run a company so
people want to get involved or give it a
try how can they find you exactly so i
feel the luckiest guy on the planet i'm
co-owner of the las vegas sup kaya club
and basically my passion my hobby my
sport and my work is all the same
because i'm out there on the colorado
river my company guiding tours kayaking
tours at the black canyon from hoover
dam down to willow beach or up to
emerald cave awesome well i'm so excited
for you guys good luck you need to come
back and tell us how it was when you
broke the record okay we will we're
putting it out there into the universe
thank you guys good luck it's happening
tomorrow record-breaking colorado river
trail hoover dam to willow beach at
hoover dam cable and they're gonna do it
i believe in you guys we've got this
mercedes i'll send it over to you
coming up on